The joe rogan experience.
I don't think that there's much truth
in today's progressive left. No,
I think there's an ideological war going
on and I think especially with Trump in
office,
they feel like the gloves are off and
all rules are out the window and anything
goes.
Yeah,
I think people are flabbergasted and while
I was telling Jamie at for the shower,
like I'm not,
I'm not without my criticisms for Trump,
but I got it meant every time stuff just
rolls off his back like water on a duck.
I started fucking laughing like they
were like the stormy Daniels things going
to sink them.
I have,
I have a friend of mine who's who's gay
and he's the nicest guy in the world,
but he's so ridiculous. He's like, that's
our Monica Lewinsky. She's our Monica.
I go, dude, it's not going to work. I go,
no one's going to care. It's going to,
it's going to disappear in a couple of
weeks ago. We're in a 10 hour new cycle.
Do you understand this?
I go in 10 hours,
some new shit comes along and nobody gives
a fuck about Brett Ratner anymore and
nobody gives a fuck about this guy.
Nobody.
And there's a new guy and there's a new
thing and there's a new problem and it's
a new thing. There's a new thing and
you saying that this porn star thing,
this is not 1994 this porn star
thing is not going to sink him.
He's going to deny it.
Fake News,
fake news and he's going to keep moving
and there's going to be nothing. Yeah,
I don't even, I don't even know
what happened with that exactly,
but to me I was remember I just was like,
I got to disconnect for a bit because
I've been just going, going, going.
So I disconnected and I'm like kind of
popped my head in for half a day just
because we're moving to a new studio,
kind of like you've been doing and pop my
head. It was like, well, what's in there?
What's this outrage right now?
Do I need to know about Donald Trump?
And they said no.
Yeah,
he called a Haiti a shit hole and I
just popped my head back on. I'm like,
of course it is. That's it. No one
cares. He was like, of course Haiti is.
It doesn't mean you hate Haitians.
Said,
why did these people from these
shithole countries want to come here?
That's what he supposedly said. He says
he didn't say it. Some people say he did.
Other people say he didn't. Who Cares?
So we're in a weird quagmire. Yeah.
If he says that he did.
Yeah.
It's not the appropriate thing for a
president of the United States to say.
But does it make sense that
Donald Trump would say that? Yes.
You want to know all,
you know it's a shit hole because French
Canadians are some of the most racist
people you will find. Love you mom.
But they create these French laws.
I've talked about this before.
Pure Glen,
it means pure wool because they want to
get rid of all the England phones. Right?
And so then they had a huge Haitian
immigration because there's a lot of,
you know,
French and people from Cameroon I special
diseases and breeding and they were
furious. So they tried to create laws to
keep the Haitians out because they were,
you know, they, it was just a clash
of cultures. Here's the thing,
Haiti is whether Donald Trump said it
or not, as a country, a shitty place,
and I don't think anyone cares anymore,
doesn't mean I hate Haitians,
doesn't mean I'm not empathetic to them.
But how fortunate that
they're in a bad place.
But how was it racist if especially
you're criticizing a government which
comprises of black people who
are screwing a black citizenry.
They've been doing it for decades.
They've never gotten it right.
Rainn Wilson took a picture from sandals,
like a pickle picture
from Club Med sandals.
Most people don't even know what that
is. The resort. That's so funny. Yeah,
I think it is. It's a Bahamas, I
think Jamaica, a few of those things.
This is one of those places.
No local,
no locale and come all the
other shit holes. I mean,
I just think it's one of those
things where I think if nothing else,
Donald Trump has allowed people
and we weren't Trump people.
We've got so much flak from the alt right
because we didn't support them. Right.
I remember that. And you were more
in support of Ted Cruz, right? Oh,
I'll let Carly Fiorina and Ben Shapiro.
I mean Ben Carson a little bit. Right.
I just thought it was hysterical. Oh,
he's smart guy. He's like, it's so
crazy. Yeah, he's like a Jim Henson care.
My favorite thing was him with Jesus,
the painting, but Jesus on his shoulder,
my woe,
Ben.
So you can get a neuro surgeon because
you were an absolute genius in that,
but you don't have the sense of like,
maybe I in put Jesus on
myself like I'm a car.
Well Jordan Peterson said
something that's very brilliant.
He said there is absolutely no correlation
with being smart and being wise.
It's true.
There's a lot of people that
are really fucking smart things,
but they are not wise in terms of how
they behave and how they think and how
they conduct their life.
Okay.